use substitution to solve for x and y
and we have a system of equations here
the first equation is 2y is equal to x
plus 7 and the second equation here is x
is equal to
y minus 4. so we want to do when they
say substitution what we want to do is
substitute one of the variables with an
expression so that we have an equation
and only one variable and then we can
solve for it let me let me show you what
i'm talking about so let me rewrite this
first equation 2y
is equal to x plus 7 and we have the
second equation over here that x
is equal to y minus 4. so if we're
looking for an x and a y that satisfies
both constraints what we could say is
well look if the x and y's have to
satisfy both constraints both of these
constraints have to be true so x must be
equal to y minus 4. so anywhere in this
top equation where we see an x
anywhere we see an x we say well look
that x by the second constraint has to
be equal to y minus 4. so everywhere we
see an x we can substitute it with a
y minus 4. so let's do that so if we
substitute
y minus 4 for x in this top equation the
top equation becomes
2y
is equal to instead of an x the second
constraint set tells us that x needs to
be equal to y minus 4. so instead of an
x we'll write a
y minus 4 and then we have a plus 7. we
have a plus seven all i did here is i
substituted all i did is i substituted y
minus four for x the second constraint
tells us that we need to do it y minus
four needs to be equal to x or x needs
to be equal to y minus four the value
here is now we have an equation one
equation with one variable we can just
solve for y so we get 2y
is equal to
y and then we have minus 4 plus 7. so y
plus 3
we can subtract y from both sides
could subtract y from both sides of this
equation the left-hand side 2y minus y
is just y
y is equal to these cancel out y is
equal to 3 and then we can go back and
substitute into either of these
equations to solve for x this is easier
right over here so let's substitute
right over here x needs to be equal to y
minus 4 so we could say that x
we could say that x is equal to 3 minus
3 minus 4 which is equal to
negative 1. so a solution the solution
to this system is x is equal to negative
1 and y is equal to three and you can
verify that it works in this top
equation right over here two times three
is six which is indeed equal to negative
one plus seven
now i wanna show you that over here we
substituted we had an expression that
was or we had an equation that
explicitly solved for x so we were able
to substitute the x's what i want to
show is we could have done it the other
way around we could have solved for y
and then substituted for the y's so
let's do that and we could have
substituted from one constraint into the
other constraint or vice versa either
way we would have gotten the same exact
answer so instead of saying x is equal
to y minus 4
in that second equation
if we add 4 to both sides of this
equation we get x
we get x plus 4 is equal to y
this and this is the exact same
constraint i just added 4 to both sides
of this to get this constraint over here
and now since we've solved
this equation explicitly for y we can
use the the first constraint the first
equation and everywhere we see a y we
can substitute it with x plus four
so it's two times instead of two times y
we can write two times
x plus four
two times x plus four is equal to x plus
seven
we can distribute this two so it gets
two x
plus eight
is equal to x plus seven
we can
subtract x from both sides of this
equation
and then we can subtract 8 from both
sides of this equation
subtract 8. the left-hand side these
that cancels out we're just left with an
x on the right hand side that cancels
out and we are left with a negative one
then we can substitute back over here we
have y is equal to x plus four or so y
is equal to negative one plus four which
is equal to 3. so once again we got the
same answer even though this time we
substituted for y instead of
substituting for x hopefully you found
that interesting